ich weiß jetzt dass harrys teils war da
gerade oben gelaufen ist aber wenn es
herr ist herzlich willkommen wir heute
davon
ich weiß die klassen schon tolle tolle
reaktionen danke freunde bei dem format
überreagiert geht es darum dass ihr mir
videos einsenden könnt und ich reagiere
darauf also her losgeht groß machen
ich kann nicht mal richtig fahrrad
fahren und er das gibt von mir auf jeden
fall der in der woche findest du das
sieht auch aus enthüllte sie ihn auf
rissen es sieht jetzt nicht so aus als
wird sie ihnen aufreizend finde ich aber
es sieht so aus als hätte sie bock auf
seine nase also irgendwie als wenn ihr
die nase abreißen würde das coole solche
einblendungen freut mich immer so was zu
bekommen die man fast meinen namen auf
den großmeistern ist einfach die
toilette wird
wenn euch dieses format hier luca
reagiert übrigens gefällt meine damen
und händler lassen war leichter und bei
30.000 live vor der das passiert nämlich
gar nichts warum mein gott ich weiß
nicht wie es bei äußere ist aber ich zum
beispiel habe ein bisschen flugangst und
wenn ich weiß okay ich sitze im flugzeug
und das ist relativ klein ich bin zum
beispiel mit max nach sylt geflogen
das hat ihnen den rathaussturm gedauert
und in das flugzeug passt so 30 leute es
hat geruckelt ich bekomme da auf jeden
fall immer mega es so wenn dann
irgendwie luftlöcher am start sind und
windböen und turbulenzen und so näherte
seinem flug sei nur zwei leute
reinpassen
einmal du hast zehnmal so große glück
nicht wie dumm kann man sein
[Musik]
ich weiß jetzt dass harrys teils war der
da gerade oben gelaufen ist aber wer ist
nämlich ist das der gleiche typ der mir
beim letzten luca reagiert auch so
komisch das video eingesetzt hatte also
ich weiß nicht was mit ihr los ist oder
was falsch läuft in deinem leben aber
was läuft falsch in meinem leben ich
habe keine ahnung warum du mir ein video
einstiegs war motion irgend so ein feuer
pilz hier entsteht aber ganz im ernst
ich kann auch für der explosion sorgen
und zwar ist dass sie mein kamera deckel
jetzt relativ weg täglich wenn ich
diesen artikel nehme und dahinter die
ecke schmeißen freude seht ihr schon das
dann passiert und zwar ich weiß da hin
und her ist kaputt gegangen
da kann man nicht mal klappt ich meine
damen und herren also so ein video da
geht wirklich jemanden und kommen jetzt
einfach weiter bank klasse versagen hier
wie lange bleibt nur noch folgende da
geht wirklich jemand in wald und wie
könnte ich stelle das ganze jetzt mach
ich habe zwar keinen kreis in dem man
aber ich muss auch sagen können direkt
beim autoabsatz loki schmidt sitzt da
wirklich in st rollercoaster schreibt
programmiersprachen ich habe übrigens
gerade einem steilstück außenminister
von de das hier habe ich gerade an das
ist allerdings keins der artikel die
neue am ersten zwölf launischen werten
ihr wisst freundin ersten zwölf wir eine
neue kollektion ist relativ genau in
zwei monaten sogar ich habe euch ja
schon den heutige zeit gehabt ihr
abgestimmt
und da ist es wirklich dabei
rausgekommen war die abstimmung
aufzulösen ist der blaue quasi
produziert wird eventuell könnt ihr euch
noch an den block erinnern dass ich euch
nämlich gefragt wollt ihr pink gelb oder
blau quasi im shop haben blauert
geworden deswegen kommt der blaue auf
jeden fall am ersten 1200 die kollektion
mit reinen die anderen produkte die
launischen werten werde ich euch vorerst
noch nicht zeigen beziehungsweise werden
wir bei instagram und snapshot und
twitter folgt dann
seht ihr die ja immer mal so ab und zu
wenn ich dir rumhängen habe oder so aber
erste zwölfte fertigen kalender
streichen
am 17 10 kommt noch eine pizza
[Musik]
das ist so schön dass nicht immer
klavier videos bekommen seitdem ich ab
und zu post dass sich jetzt selber auch
klavier lernen
die sache ist leider dass ich seit zwei
wochen nicht mehr güter man bei mir ist
es auch irgendwie immer so dass ich mir
nicht aussuchen und das ist ein perfekt
lernen sondern ich werde das nicht zu 50
prozent und dann habe ich schon bock auf
dem nächstes lied zur total dumm
eigentlich danke für das video
du wirst später bestimmt
wenn mir langweilig isst dann esse ich
pizza
warum will ich eigentlich noch nicht
4000 tonnen hoch her du gehst ja jeden
tag duschen diese stinkst du denn
eigentlich immer noch korrekt egal
danke dafür mega freundlich damit will
ich an dieser stelle jetzt allerdings
auch das heutige luca reagiert beenden
ich hoffe es hat euch gefallen wer das
getan hat lassen leichter wird mal der
name hat 30.000 leid was halten
vielleicht gar nichts trotzdem schauen
wir das luxury flugshow es steht sogar
ein fucking die stadt schafft mit 30.000
flex kommen lassen
da schreibt man in die kommentare luca
reagiert werden wollte dass dieses
format öfter hochladen und jetzt meine
damen und herren kommt dass auch dass
die meisten leute wichtiger als erwartet
wenn sie mir vom land gegen das auto
das kommt jetzt das was sie vom bio das
was jetzt hier von video
hier können jetzt hier in einen kanal
abonnieren oder hier unten meinen job
ausschenken jetzt findet ihr zwei andere
videos und wenn ihr schon abonnent seid
könnt ihr auf die glocke klicken dann
bekommen die benachrichtigungen
[Musik]